b
[music]
thank you very much and at the end
the statement
of the Council follows again, minister, you have the
floor, please, chairperson, and
adapt
flexibly, thank you, minister, this
concludes the debate on this item on the
agenda, we will continue with
the next item on the agenda
the declarations of the council and the
commission initiative of the european
union for pollinators i
would like to remind you once again that you
have the option of registering your spontaneous requests to speak
or the blue card both in the usual way and electronically, and
that's where we start in the  debate
on pollinators back on the bike madam
minister does prepare you have
the floor again please
let minister
now
let thanks and took a moment
but here i am chairman
consulting us inc
eight active family paris colonies of
bees
diversity of the  witch and the f  act that
causes of the world